yo yo yo
yo i got about 20 minutes before my hair
stops looking
fresh so we gotta swing into this
spider-man action spider-man 3
multiverse teaser
from sony law i think that means
latin america oh let's can't wait to see
what's in store
it's moving to hbo max all of the
spider-man movies are
getting released on hbo max moving
forward uh let's see who's in store
we're gonna watch uh the trailer along
with kazakh wonders video
which i'm hoping has some english
translations for some things let's do
this
oh yeah we're gonna be filming our
mandalorian reaction later this explains
the shirt
which i might change out of feels a
little tight not feeling confident
you look so buff though i changed my
mind
ah oh toby
toby favorite toby toby
what does this trailer mean it's moving
a sony streaming service
multiverso del marvel
[Music]
uh-huh
so many possibilities i think that said
they're all in spider-man 3.
i wish this this makes me wish i chose
to take spanish rather than latin
makes me wish i paid attention if things
trailer of what the spider-man
multiverse live-action spider-verse
could be
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things mcu and if you don't
know what this trailer said don't worry
i'll translate
everything forward what we saw and i'll
also release this week's giveaway winner
at the end of the video
so to start things off this trailer is
coming from the channel
sony channel latino america and this is
in latin america as if you check their
twitter that they have listed on their
youtube channel
it takes you to the same twitter name
that is a verified twitter account
okay the website that they have listed
takes you directly to the latin america
officials
god damn it warren translated teasing me
with all this words
preparation for ccxp but let's go ahead
and translate each part of the video
so it starts off by saying news about
spider-man 3.
who is your favorite spider-man
immediately after that garfield
oh absolutely everyone knows from 2002
he's the classic peter parker
and then of course it shows tom holland
from 2017 to
the present time so it asks who your
favorite spider-man is but then after it
shows all this footage it says
you don't have to choose it shows a
picture of
what and then it says in the marvel
universe
anything can happen
it is very
they're having fun with us
which it very much seems like it is then
this is it this
is the spider verse now as i mentioned
in my video yesterday
today is the start of come on ccxp
is the comic con experience that takes
place in brazil and ccxp
recently tweeted that sony pictures
planned on making their presence
known at ccxp this means that they're
going to do or
unveil something very big and we were or
beat a fan
stabbed someone with a pencil in
december of 2020
this month and this video is definitely
not the spider-man 3
first look video that we were promised
however it definitely is okay
with the film that's awesome teasing the
spider verse it's asking
which spider-man is your favorite and
then says you don't have to choose
because in the marvel universe anything
is possible and they very blatantly said
we may see all three spider-man come
together
so this does seem to be confirmation
that spider-man 3 is in fact
going to be a live-action spider-verse
film with toby mcguire returning as his
spider-man and andrew garfield returning
as his spider-man
and it's looking like spider-man 3 is
going to probably be one of the biggest
marvel movies of all time so this is it
it looks like it's finally
happening and hopefully we'll get an
announcement from sony this weekend at
ccxp
and possibly our very first look at
spider-man
3. that is pretty to be a pretty good
ending to 2020 after all which of course
we needed after this year
so let me know how yes it solves
everything
especially the dilemma of how we're
going to watch it congratulations to
youtube user cliff springer for being
the winner of this week's
good job cliff giveaway just did it in
the email
and some great gift ideas for the
holidays be sure to check them out be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest mcu news and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
indeed indeed i am so glad we chose
because i am just contemplating
do we just watch the actual trailer or
do we just watch warren's as i feel like
warren
would take that extra time out of his
day
to learn some espanol for our non
espanol ears come on if that's what it's
saying if if it's
saying that you don't have to choose i
don't know what to say
who's your favorite spider-man it shows
all three and it says hey you don't have
to choose because anything's possible in
the mcu
yes the fact that they're doing this
just seems like it would be kind of
weird if they're going to be
showing especially after edge the whole
andrew garfield situation
it would just be kind of strange to be
promoting your spider-man 3 movie with
tom holland
and to be showcasing this it really does
seem like
they are going out there going don't
worry guys
the news you've all been waiting for
it's gonna happen we're gonna deliver it
to you don't you fret you wanna know
where toby maguire has been
the last few years he's just been in
negotiations
i mean marvel's good at keeping things
under the radar we didn't even know
haley steinfeld was kate bishop until
they were filming you know i think
because they they go out of their way to
say possibilities about spider-man 3 i
think that's your clincher right there
cause like you could argue like
oh anything's possible maybe it's some
kind of like you joked like sony
streaming service but they put
spider-man three and i think because
andrew garfield doesn't even have one
that's pretty solid evidence-focused
exactly
john you're speaking the language that i
like to hear
english that's right i woke up this
morning i was like gotta brush up on my
vocab my english my addiction
guys how excited are you about this
ninja [ __ ] so much about the
multiverse of the spider-man coming
together hell we were even on cosmic
wonders youtube channel last week doing
a podcast and most of it was about
the spider-man a multiverse crossover so
go over there
check it out for more thoughts but i'm
excited because this oh yeah
this feels everything i wanted this
feels like an actual
confirmation just as like we're this
close to getting the
the exclamation mark confirmed word you
know this close subscribe
click that notification bell keep a look
out for our mandalorian reaction
hopefully not too much drops out of cc
xp so i don't get a heart attack while
trying to catch up on patreon to do
last but not least
lance door lance my buddy my god
i've had my plan to engage to my
girlfriend who's down my fiance for
quite a while now
and i've been waiting to do this kind of
shout out for the longest time because
you've been engaged for quite some time
wife swap oh my you got a wife swap
coming up what you have to do
you and i what swapping my life
i don't know what your your soon-to-be
bride looks like but i'm sure it doesn't
matter
yeah doesn't matter it's different
that's what counts
what still taboo your stuff you and i
land
let's get it going huh i hear you
canadians are a bunch of freaks
so let's see that freaky deaky canadian
side
get mounted on on top of each other and
just go hug
crazy you should just get all four of
you together into one
big love consortium and swap with all of
four
options man the good thing is you you
kind of look like me
yeah so everybody wins my fiance might
not even know
and plus then you get the experience of
you know experiencing yourself you're
sick john you're not even involved in
this i know you're a pervert
just trying to fifth wheel lance let's
get this going
[Music]